So now let's jump into an exercise with
the normal.
for a normal distribution
and this is
one problem that you can solve one such
problem. You can solve if you understand.
the normal distribution
to solve our problem like this everything we've learned.
from day one
and
What we're going to learn today?
Is going to prepare you to solve.
most
of the problems you would find in a
statistical or a textbook that has the with
Statistics and probably Theory here's one.
It says that there are two machines for cutting
quarks intended for years and white bottles.
Okay, so you have two machines that?
You know.
produce these quirks they would fit on a wine
bottle the first
produces corks with diameters that are normally distributed
with mean three centimeters and the standard
deviation of
0.1 centimeter
Let's look at the second mission. The second machine produces corks with
diameters that have normal distribution with 3.04. So
almost the same as the
first machine. However, it standard deviation is much
smaller.
Let me stop you before I complete the last sentence
the second machine. The second machine has a
smaller standard deviation, which means if
you look at its probability distribution, it's much narrower.
And like I said if it's much narrower.
It's let's likely to vary and so it's less prone
to risk.
Let's prone to risk.
And last sentences acceptable Crooks have
diameters between 2.9 centimeters or 3.1 centimeters. So
you can't really deviate too much. You can't make corks that
are too.
Big or too small it has to be.
You know between 2.9 to 3.1.
This question says we have two machines both of
them.
produce quarks
their mean is approximately the same or virtually
the same mean.
Okay, when they when they counted.
Those quarks and they took it
took a note of their diameter.
They realized that
the mean average the mean average
of the corks.
Of the first machine and the mean average of the quirks of
the second machine.
Is the same.
Like the meaning the on average, they're very similar on average.
They're very similar. However one standard Devi one machine has
a bigger standard deviation and they want to
know
Is the standard deviation?
Too much for us. Like let's say you have this
you have to choose between two machines. Let's say one is cheaper than
the other.
the first machine is cheaper, but
it's more susceptible to variation.
Now if it varies too much, that means you cannot ship
those corks.
So you end up with more waste and you have
to do such should be pay more and get the second machine which has smaller standard
deviation or no the first machine that
has more standard deviation. It won't be too bad
like
Perhaps it has a high enough probability that
it's worth the risk.
So, how do we decide how do we use statistics?
To arrive at this answer can
we should buy the first machine or no? It's
too risky. Let's let's go in the second machine. Okay, so I'm already
giving you the answer by the way. It says which machine is more likely to produce an
acceptable work. The answer is the second machine, but let's see how we can determine this
answer.
using the CDF
using the normal distribution and using the standardized random
variable.